meine Lieben Zuschauer Russland und die
Kraft des Atoms das ist eine Geschichte
die verdammt große Ähnlichkeiten mit dem
Herrn der Ringe aufweist wie der Eine
Ring verleiht die Spaltung des Atoms den
Russen zwar große Macht korrodiert
jedoch ihre Seele macht sie mit der Zeit
bösartig und stürzt sie ins Verderben
nur durch den Besitz der Atombombe
konnte die Sowjetunion vier
jahrzehntelang als Supermarkt auf
Augenhöhe mit den USA mithalten und die
zivile Nutzung der Atome Energie war ein
zentraler Grundpfeiler ihrer
Wirtschaftskraft anderer Seite war ist
das Reaktor Unglück von Tschernobyl das
maßgeblich zum Bankrott und Zerfall das
soweit führte und heute ist Russland
neben Nordkorea die einzige Atom macht
die es wagt anderen Ländern offen mit
atomaren erst Schlägen zu drohen z.B für
den Fall dass ihre konventionelle Armee
den ukrainischen Streitkräften
unterliegen sollte natürlich wird der
atomdrucker von Putin nie so direkt ins
Spiel gebracht dafür hat er seine
met-videos sowohl Jobs und andere
atomaren droh Marionetten diese soll mit
ihrem apokalyptischen Gebell einerseits
den besten einschüchtern und
andererseits der eigenen Bevölkerung ein
vollkommen pervertiertes Gefühl der
Überlegenheit und Unbesiegbarkeit geben
aber zu diesem Thema und wieso es sich
um nichts anderes als einen gewaltigen
Bluff handelt haben wir bereits mehrere
Videos gedreht ich werde sie euch
verlinken nur für den Fall dass
irgendjemand noch wirklich Angst davor
haben sollte schaut sie euch ruhig mal
an auch damit ihr entsprechende
Argumente zur Hand haben mit denen ihr
eingeschüchterte Gemüter in eurer
Umgebung beruhigen könnt so alles andere
als ein blöd ist jedoch die wahre
atomare Trumpfkarte Russlands wovon ich
hier spreche nun schaut euch mal diese
Grafik an
ganz genau Russland stellt durchaus eine
atomare Bedrohung dar allerdings nicht
durch sein militärisches
nuklearwaffenarsenal sondern als
Großmacht der zivilen Kernkraft mit
seinen 37 Reaktoren rangiert Russland
auf Platz 4 der Länder mit den meisten
Atomreaktoren weltweit zudem dominiert
es den Markt für cambrennstoffe auf
eindrucksvolle Weise obwohl die
russischen Uranminen lediglich 5% zur
globalen Förderung bei Steuern hält
heraus Atom beeindruckende 27% des
weltweiten Uran umwandlungsanteils und
sogar 46% der Uran
anreicherungskapazitäten und das erklärt
wie wir euch hier auf visualpolitik
bereits in einem separaten Video
dargelegt haben warum der Westen keine
Sanktionen gegen Russland staatlichen
Atomkonzern verhängt hat und während
flüssig Erdgas also LNG als die Haupt
Alternative zur russischen Gas Geld gibt
es in der Kern brennstoffbranche einen
anderen wichtigen Akteur Frankreich die
hat eine weitreichende nukleare
Tradition und könnte für den Westen eine
entscheidende Rolle spielen wenn es
darum geht die Abhängigkeit von Russland
zu mindern in Paris sind sie sich über
ihre Strategie im Klaren sie wollen
nicht nur einfach weitermachen nein sie
wollen viel mehr erreichen aber
frankreich hat dazu noch einige Hürden
zu überwinden ein signifikantes Problem
ist der französische Atomsektor steckt
seit über einem Jahrzehnt in einer
Dauerkrise kaum ist eine Herausforderung
bewältigt taucht schon die nächste auf
und das jüngste Problem kam genauso
unerwartet wie es weit weg ist
Staat streichen Niger Weg Sorgen über
die Uran Abhängigkeit Frankreichs und
der EU nie gehört als die letzte Bastion
der Demokratie im Sahel Präsident war so
wurde von Frankreich als essentieller
Partner im Kampf gegen den wachsen sie
hatismus in dieser Region betrachtet
doch aktuelle Entwicklungen zeigen das
mit der neuen Militär hinter ihm nie
eine radikaler Wandel bevorstehen könnte
das Militär konfrontiert Frankreich
wiederholt mit Vorwürfen sich als
ehemalige Kolonialmacht in nigerische
Angelegenheiten einzumischen und das
Land auszubeuten es stellt sich also die
Frage inwiefern hängen die Ereignisse in
Niger mit Frankreichs Ambitionen
zusammen den kernbrennstoffmarkt zu
dominieren worin besteht die Strategie
der Regierung malcon wird der Westen in
Zukunft sein angereichertes Uran
weiterhin aus Russland beziehen müssen
heute werden wir hier auf visualpolitik
all diese Fragen beantworten und zwar
gleich nach der kurzen Botschaft unseres
tollen Sponsors LG one denn schließlich
hat LG1 das heutige Video nicht nur mit
seinem finanziellen Beitrag möglich
gemacht nein es hilft auch weit darüber
hinaus was ich damit meine 0 sicher
könnt ihr euch vorstellen dass dieser
Job nicht gerade leicht durchzuhalten
ist wenn man sich nicht ordentlich in
Form hält im vergangenen Jahr zum
Beispiel war meine Arbeitsbelastung
aufgrund des Krieges enorm angewachsen
und ich hatte Schwierigkeiten in den
Stress auf gesunde Weise zu kompensieren
die Folge waren Bewegungsmangel und
schlechte Ernährung ich musste etwas
unternehmen und als erstes habe ich
meine eigenen Routine umgestellt vor dem
proteinreichen und zuckerabend Frühstück
kommt jetzt immer eine Runde
Krafttraining um das Muskelwachstum
anzuregen davor muss jedoch erste
Energiestoffwechsel in Schwung gebracht
werden und hierbei unterstützen mich
folgende Bestandteile meiner
allmorgendlichen Portion AG one Kupfer
biotinsäure tiamin und dem Vitamine B2
B12 und C das ist nicht einfach so daher
gesagt sondern eine evidenzbasierte
Tatsache und wenn ihr mir nicht glaubt
dann schaut euch doch z.B an womit sich
Joe rotan fit hält ebenfalls auch in den
Kommentaren unter unseren Videos
schreiben uns immer wieder Zuschauer
dass sie wollen ausprobiert haben und
sehr zufrieden sind aber okay um alles
klar zu stellen ein
Nahrungsergänzungsmittel ersetzt keine
ausgewogene Ernährung deswegen heißt es
ja nur Ergänzungsmittel aber es hilft
mir eben dabei mit einer gesünderen
Routine und belastet in den Tag zu
starten allerdings ist LGO nicht nur für
meinen individuellen Anwendungsbereich
geeignet sondern bietet noch viele
weitere gesundheitliche Vorteile über
die ihr mehr erfahren könnt wenn ihr auf
den Link in der Beschreibung klickt dort
erfahrt ihr auch weitere Details darüber
welche Inhaltsstoffe genau welchen
Nutzen bringen und wie sie optimal
aufeinander abgestimmt sind um zu
energieeffekte und eine hohe Bio
Verfügbarkeit zu erzielen fakt ist nun
mal Agon ist Kita freundlich und die 75
wertvollen Mikronährstoffe wurden aus
echten natürlichen veganen
Nahrungsmitteln wie Erbsen oder Soja
gewonnen ohne künstliche Zusatzstoffe
außerdem schmeckt es auch noch gut mir
zumindest
natürlich darf man es wie alles nicht
überdosieren sollte auf Allergene achten
und vor allem nicht einnehmen wenn man
schwanger ist oder stillt ich empfehle
euch auf jeden Fall mal eine
Ernährungsberatung zu machen um
festzustellen was ihr braucht um euch
besser zu fühlen und gesünder zu leben
mir persönlich hilft die oben genannte
Kombination mit LG von am besten denn es
deckt meine Ansicht nach die meisten
Fälle zufriedenstellend ab passend dazu
bietet LG1 unsere Community sogar ein
besonderes Angebot wenn du auf den Link
in der Videobeschreibung klickst
erhältst du bei Abschluss eines
monatlichen Abos einen kostenlosen
Jahresvorrat an Vitamin D3 und K2 und 5
praktische Praxis für unterwegs gratis
dazu Neukunden halten außerdem das LG
und welcome Cat inklusive schicker
Aufbewahrungsdose und einen praktischen
Shaker zur Monats Packungen dazu das
ganze ist ein Abo ohne Laufzeit wenn Du
und Du kannst es jederzeit nach Belieben
anpassen pausieren und kündigen also
worauf wartest du noch probiere ich die
wollen doch einfach mal ganz
unverbindlich aus und unterstütze auch
deine Ernährung auf einfach und gesund
unde Weise übrigens falls ihr auch
unsere Arbeit direkt unterstützen
möchtet könnt ihr dies über die Spenden
Link in der Beschreibung tun auf das wir
euch noch viele weitere interessante
Videos wie dieses liefern können und
wenn ihr das alles erledigt habt können
wir jetzt in die Geschichte der
französischen Atomindustrie eintauchen
aufgepasst
[Applaus]
[Musik]
atomkolonialismus
lasst uns mal 50 Jahre zurückblicken die
berühmt berüchtigte ölpreis-krise
erschütterte die Welt innerhalb
kürzester Zeit verviertfachte sich der
Ölpreis als arabische Länder beschlossen
ihre Produktion aus politischen Gründen
drastisch zu drosseln in dieser Zeit
generierte Frankreich ein Land ohne
eigene Ölreserven den Großteil seines
Stroms in ölkraftwerken wohin gegen nur
bescheidene 5% Ausatmen Energie standen
genau diese Krise war der Auslöser für
den sogenannten Plan im Jahr 1974
präsentierte wir müssen mehr der
damalige Premierminister und der
Präsident Pompidou ein ehrgeiziges
Vorhaben erstreckte danach Frankreichs
fast vollständige Energieabhängigkeit
von ausländischen Erdöl zu durchbrechen
sein Ziel waren nichts geringeres als
der baut dutzende Atomreaktoren auf der
grünen Wiese und etwas sehr Wichtiges
was er dafür brauchte war Uran als
cambrennstoff ja und die französische
Atomenergiekommission wusste bereits wo
sie dieses wertvolle Element finden
konnte so mehr
seit vielen Jahren zu den größten
uranmien weltweit wir haben euch von den
unfallenen Praktiken dieser beiden durch
den französischen Staat kontrollierten
Unternehmen bereits in unserem letzten
nigervideo berichtet ich werde euch
verlinken für den Fall dass ihr es noch
nicht gesehen haben solltet
interessanterweise stolperte Frankreich
bereits 1957 über Uran Vorkommen in
Niger damals war es noch eine Kolonie
und als Niger 1960 seine Unabhängigkeit
erklärte sicherte sich Frankreich durch
ein Abkommen bevorzugten Zugriff auf
diese Bodenschätze auf diese Weise
begann Ende der 1960er Jahre die groß
angelegte Ausbeutung dieser uraninen
dort konnten einige französische Akteure
all die üblen Praktiken anwenden die sie
bereits in Gabun eingeübt hatten
wir müssen nämlich wissen dass
Frankreich bereits 1960 mit dem Betrieb
der uralmine kaputt begonnen hatte aber
Ende der 1960er Jahre stellte man durch
Messungen erschreckend hohe Werte von
Gamma und Alphastrahlung bei den
dortigen Arbeitern Fest eine Anpassung
an die in Frankreich geltenden
strahlenschutzstandard hätte erhebliche
Investitionen erfordert doch darauf
hatte man in Paris offenbar keine Lust
die von den französischen Monsieurs
präferierte Lösung war viel
kostengünstiger man verdreifachte kurze
Hand die Grenzwerte ab denen die
Strahlenbelastung als gefährlich für die
menschliche Gesundheit geht
genau solche Praktiken illustrieren die
Privilegien die Frankreich durch seinen
Minen in ehemaligen Kolonien genoss
geringere Kosten da weder für die
Sicherheit der Arbeit dann noch für
deren Löhne auf dem gleichen Niveau
gesorgt wurde wie in anderen Regionen
und vielleicht fragt sich ja der ein
oder andere jetzt naja aber hat der Uran
abbaut trotz aller Umweltbelastung dem
Niger zumindest wirtschaftliche Vorteile
gebracht nun leider nein die
ausbeutungsabkommen machten ihrem Namen
wahrlich alle Ehre die Franzosen konnten
fast den ganzen Reibach für sich
einstreichen man kann hier klick und
klar von Missbrauch sprechen
jahrzehntelang entrichteten französische
Bergbauunternehmen lediglich 5,5% ihrer
Einnahmen an die griechische Regierung
zum Vergleich in Kanada und Kasachstan
wo das Unternehmen uranusa den späten
1990er Jahren ebenfalls Uran abbaut
getragen diese Konzessionsabgaben 13 bzw
18,5 %. das krasse Missverhältnis wird
besonders deutlich wenn man sich die
Mengen an abgebauten Uran im Vergleich
zu den Einnahmen der jeweiligen Länder
anschaut folgende Grafik veranschaulicht
ist doch im Jahr 2014 wurde ein neues
Abkommen zwischen Niger und Urano das
damals noch unter arriva femierte
ausgehandelt die Lizenzgebühr wurde von
5,5 auf etwa 12 % angehoben sofern
bestimmte Bedingungen hinsichtlich der
Rentabilität und des uranpreises erfüllt
worden okay die Bedingungen haben sich
leicht verbessert aber frankreich hat in
Niger weiterhin einen gewissen Vorteil
gegenüber dem internationalen Markt wenn
wir dazu noch die Tatsache
berücksichtigen dass Niger eines der
ärmsten Länder der Welt ist können wir
sicherlich von einem weiteren Fall des
Neokolonialismus in Verbindung mit dem
ressourcenflug Sprechen von diesen
sprechen Ökonomen wenn eine
Volkswirtschaft durch den Verkauf ihrer
natürlichen Rohstoffe in eine
Abwärtsspirale Gerät wir haben euch
bereits in früheren Videos erklärt was
die sogenannte holländische Krankheit
ist dabei kommt es gleich zu mehrere
negativen Effekten für die Menschen
eines Landes wenn seine
Haupteinnahmequelle in Export einfach zu
fördernde Rohstoffe ohne großen Bedarf
der Erzeugung eines Mehrwerts besteht
zum einen wird die Wirtschaft eben
einseitig auf diese relativ stumpfe
Tätigkeit ausgerichtet was die
werkstätige Bevölkerung nicht gerade
kompetent und wettbewerbsfähig macht und
zum anderen wird ein Großteil der
Geldströme ins Land durch die
Regierenden selbst kontrolliert es
entsteht ein Zustand bei dem der Staat
sein eigenes Volk nicht mehr braucht um
sich zu finanzieren und das Risiko dass
er sich deswegen von den Interessen der
Menschen total abkoppelt und durch und
durch korrupt wird steigt ins
unermessliche macht vor wie man diese
Falle vermeiden kann und wir haben auch
schon Videos über diesen positiven Fall
gedreht aber es handelt sich bei
Norwegen eben um eine große Ausnahme und
Niger fällt ganz bestimmt in dem
mehrheitskategorie der Beispiele wie man
es nicht machen sollte genau aus diesem
Grund wäre die Übertragung der
Uranförderung in niedrige Hände so
verachtenswert die Rolle Frankreichs
auch sein mag ebenfalls keine besonders
gute Idee es gibt in dem Land sogar
schon einen Präzedenzfall dafür
[Musik]
im Jahr 1974 inszenierte Oberstleutnant
senique einen Staatsstreich Kunze der
bis 1987 Präsident war stellt
anschließend die Forderung auf einen
Teil des geförderten uranoxids direkt zu
erhalten und zwar jeden Prozentsatz der
der Beteiligung des Staates Niger an den
griechischen Tochtergesellschaften der
französischen Bergbauunternehmen
entspricht dieser beträgt immerhin mehr
als 30% auch diese Weise wollte concier
das Uran auf eigene Rechnung auf den
internationalen Markt werfen das Problem
lag jedoch in seiner sagen wir mal
erlesenen Kundenliste Saddam Husseins
Irak da darf ich liebe ihn Pakistan und
so weiter und so fort kunshine wird
Ersatz zugeschrieben wir werden Uran
sogar an den Teufel verkaufen wenn es
sein muss ja und ich weiß was sie jetzt
denkt da die aktuelle Militär herunter
die mega die Macht übernommen hat auf
Rache an Frankreich aus ist werden Sie
sicherlich die Vereinbarung zur
Ausbeutung ihrer Mienen brechen sie
werden orano aus dem Land vertreiben und
Frankreich wird das gesamte Uran in
nieder verlieren und wenn man bedenkt
dass Atomkraftwerke etwas 70 % des
französischen Stroms erzeugen würde
Frankreichs Energieproduktion sicher ins
Banken geraten wenn das niedliche
Militär plötzlich die uranlieferung
unterbricht oder nun nein anders als
Deutschland bei russischen Gas hat
Frankreich seine Hausaufgaben gemacht
und zwar auf außerordentlich
vorbildliche Weise
[Musik]
Paris ist es gelungen seine
uranversorgung zu diversifizieren wenn
wir uns die Daten der letzten 10 Jahre
anschauen kamen
88.200 Tonnen natur-oradi Frankreich
importierte hauptsächlich aus drei
Ländern kasachstagen mit 27% Niger mit
20 und Usbekistan mit 19%. auch die
Einfuhren aus Australien und Namibia
tragen mit jeweils 14% heraus was die
jährlichen Daten angeht so machte Uran
aus Niger in keinem einzigen Jahr mehr
als 35% der französischen importer aus
[Musik]
diese Daten sind ähnlich wie die von
Urano im Jahr 2010 lieferten die
nigerischen Minen zwei Drittel der
weltweiten Produktion nach der
Schließung der komenjakmine im Jahr 2021
liefert Niger allerdings nur noch
weniger als ein Drittel das bedeutet das
Nigers Uran dass einst entscheidend für
die Versorgung der Kernkraftwerke war
heute für das französische Energiesystem
nur noch von relativer Bedeutung ist und
nur noch knapp 20 % importierten Urans
ausmacht vergleicht das einfach mal mit
den 60%, die Russland für die deutsche
Erdgasversorgung ausgemacht hat mit
anderen Worten wenn Niger den urananen
zu dreht kann Frankreich das Uran
problemlos durch Importe aus anderen
Ländern ersetzen so allerdings bedeutet
das nicht dass diese Unterbrechung keine
Auswirkungen haben würde nein es würde
sich um einen Herden Rückschlag für die
Strategie des Landes Handeln eine
Alternative zu Russland auf dem Markt
für Kernbrennstoffe aufzubauen deswegen
weiß auch so wichtig für den family
militärhunde in Niger als Verbündeten zu
fördern und deswegen wird Putin auch um
jeden Preis versuchen sie dort an der
Macht zu halten okay aber wie sieht denn
überhaupt die französische Strategie für
Kanada aus und welche Rolle spielen
Russland und nieder darin passt jetzt
gut auf denn an dieser Stelle wird es
besonders spannend
ein von Russland beherrscht am Markt
genauso wie Gas und kombikraftwerke
Erdgas als Brennstoff für die
Stromerzeugung nutzen brauchen
Atomkraftwerke ihren eigenen Brennstoff
der in Atomreaktoren am häufigsten
verwendete Prozess zu Energieerzeugung
ist die Kernspaltung dafür braucht man
ein Element das spaltbar ist und sich
leicht spalten lässt und hier kommt Uran
ins Spiel aber genauso wie ihr Erdöl
Raffinieren müsst um Kraftstoffe wie
Benzin oder Diesel zu erhalten müsst ihr
Uran auch erstmal anreichern damit es
als Brennstoff in Atomkraftwerken
überhaupt verwendet werden kann der
Prozess ist sehr selten wie beim Bau von
Atombomben der Unterschied liegt aber im
Grad der Anreicherung der benötigt wird
[Musik]
besteht so 99,3% aus den nicht
spaltbaren uranen 238 Isotopen der
spaltbare Teil die oral 235 Isotop
machen nur 0,7 % aus angereichert ab
einer Konzentration von 3 bis 5 %, U235
kann das oral jedoch als kernstoff für
Kraftwerke dienen die Strom erzeugen auf
bis zu 20 % angereichertes Uran wird so
Herstellung medizinischer Isotope
verwendet die vor allem bei der Diagnose
bestimmter krebsartner eingesetzt werden
und um eine Bombe zu bauen muss die
Anreicherung auf 90% erhöht werden
so und jetzt kommt das worauf wir die
ganze Zeit hinaus wollen nämlich der
Grund wieso der internationale Markt für
cambron Stoff ausgerechnet von Russland
dominiert wird traditionell wird Uran
nämlich mit zwei verschiedenen Methoden
angereichert der besten entschied sich
für die einfache Methode die gasdefusion
das Problem dieser einfachen Methode sie
ist außerordentlich teuer da sie viel
Energie für die Anreicherung des Urans
benötigt über wie viel Energie wir reden
nun damit ihr euch eine Vorstellung
machen könnt die Anreicherungsanlage die
in Frankreich Ende der 1970er Jahre
eröffnet wurde verbrauchte sage und
schreibe 15 Terabyte Stunden pro Jahr
das ist die gleiche Menge an Strom die
über sechseinhalb Millionen Elektroautos
während eines ganzen Jahres verbrauchen
würden selbst auf dem größten
europäischen Automarkt Deutschland
fahren heute aber nur etwa eine Million
Elektroautos herum in Frankreich
natürlich noch mal ein gutes Stück
weniger kurz gesagt der Energie
verbraucht dieser Anreicherungsanlage
war einfach gigantisch
[Musik]
in den drei Jahrzehnten ihres Betriebs
war die Ural Anreicherungsanlage George
Best ergrößte Stromverbraucher
Frankreichs sie verbrauchte etwa 4% der
gesamten französischen Stromproduktion
tatsächlich wurden auf dem Höhepunkt des
Kalten Krieges etwa 7% der gesamten US
Stromerzeugung für die ureinreichung
verwendet sowohl für militärische als
auch für zivil
aber naja die Gasdiffusion war eben die
Methode für die sich der Westen
entschieden hatte und was taten sie auf
der anderen Seite des Eisernen Vorhangs
nun das verwirrtische Atomprogramm ist
allen gut bekannt sowohl in Bezug auf
die Rüstung als auch auf die Atomenergie
die UdSSR nahm etwa 30 Reaktoren in
Betrieb und bei der uranane Erreichung
entschied sie sich für eine komplexere
Technik die Zentrifugation ja diese ist
technisch aufwendiger allerdings
verbraucht diese Methode 50 mal weniger
Energie als die Gasdiffusion und genau
diese Fehlentscheidung aus der Zeit des
Kalten Krieges erklärt warum wir noch
heute mitten im Jahr 2023 Nachrichten
wie diese zu lesen bekommen gut jeden
Verkauf den USA noch immer
Kernbrennstoff im Wert von fast 1
Milliarde Dollar als sie es probiert
Union 1991 sehr viel vereinbarten die
USA und das neue Russland das sogenannte
Megatonnen zu megawatt-programm
[Musik]
hoch angereichertes Uran aus ehemaligen
sowjetischen Atomsprengköpfen wurde in
niedrig angereichertes Uran umgewandelt
und in die USA verschifft um es in
zivilen Anlagen zu verbrennen angesichts
des kostenunterschieds waren alle
westlichen Stromversorgungsunternehmen
ganz heiß darauf dass billige
angereicherte Uran aus Russland zu
kaufen dabei profitierten sie von der
kostengünstigeren Technologie der
sowjeta das Problem war ja noch dass sie
dadurch gleichzeitig zum Ruinen der
Anlagen im Westen beitrugen die noch mit
Gasdiffusion arbeiteten aber natürlich
waren in den Glücklichen 1990er Jahren
die alkoholreserven das einzige was
unter Bares jetzt hin Gefahr lief zur
Neige zu gehen und so erlangte Russland
eine marktbeherrschende Stellung von der
Hausordnung der 2007 von Wladimir Putin
gegründete Staatskonzern der russische
Riese auf dem globalen atomenergiemarkt
außerordentlich profitiert hat ein Riese
der selbst unter den widrigsten
Bedingungen absolut unantastbar ist der
Druck auf die EU raus Atom im nächsten
Russland Sanktionspaket zu sanktionieren
weder Brüssel noch Washington haben es
gewagt den kennt dann Stoff von rossaton
zu sanktionieren die USA haben die
Anreicherung von Uran schon vor Jahren
eingestellt und etwa ein Drittel des von
Ihnen verwendeten kennenlernstoß wird
aus Russland importiert in größten und
zugleich billigsten Produzenten der Welt
trotzdem beträgt die Rechnung jedes Jahr
immerhin fast eine Milliarde Dollar tja
wäre es jedoch angesichts brutalen
Krieges gegen die Ukraine im Zuge all
der deswegen verhängten Sanktion gegen
russisches Erdöl Erdgas und tausende
russische Unternehmen und Produkte nicht
irgendwie ideal bei der Versorgung mit
Kernbrennstoff ebenfalls nicht mehr vom
Kreml abhängig zu sein nun natürlich wer
ist das und genau dieser Stelle kommt
eben Frankreichs große Strategien
gespielt aufgepasst
[Musik]
Alter steht erst am Anfang
meine Lieben Zuschauer wenn ihr in
atomofländern die Deutschland Österreich
oder Spanien lebt werdet ihr vielleicht
überrascht sein aber Kernkraft ist
weltweit tatsächlich der letzte Schrei
zur Zeit werden über den ganzen Globus
verteilt 59 neue Atomreaktoren gebaut
diese Zahl soll in den nächsten Jahren
um weitere 111 ansteigen und jetzt
haltet euch fest wie Pläne der
jeweiligen Staaten sehen den Bau
weiterer 321 Atomanlagen vor 40% dieser
Reaktoren befinden sich in China oder
werden dort gebaut aber auch andere
Mächte die Russland und Indien
investieren massiv in die Atomkraft
sogar in den USA gibt es ernsthafte
Pläne zur Wiederbelebung dieser
Industrie ja und auch in Europa gibt es
Länder die nicht abgehängt werden wollen
frankreich hat bereits vor dem Krieg in
der Ukraine angekündigt dass es sechs
neue Reaktoren bauen will aber die
Franzosen sind nur die Spitze des
Eisbergs die Liste der europäischen
Staaten die eine starke Ausweitung der
atomkraftplanung und aktiv angehen ist
wahrlich beeindruckend Großbritannien
Polen die Niederlande Slowenien die
Slowakei Tschechien Ungarn Bulgarien
Rumänien Estland und Litauen und selbst
das könnte erst der Anfang sein denn es
ist sehr wahrscheinlich dass ich weitere
Länder anschließen werden nachdem er die
Europäische Union diese Technologie
ihrer programmatisch Unterstützung auch
demokratisch zugesichert hat
EU-Parlament befürwortet Kennzeichnung
von Gas und atominvestitionen als
umweltfreundlich die Energie und
Verkehrswende und der Kampf gegen den
Klimawandel erfordern Investitionen in
neue Technologien und man darf keine
davon aus ideologischen Gründen
ignorieren die die Erhaltung unserer
Lebensqualität bei gleichzeitiger
Reduzierung der Treibhausgasemissionen
und Abhängigkeit von Diktatur ermöglicht
genau aus diesem Grund hat Brüssel
beschlossen dass erneuerbare Energien
und Kerne Energie Hand in Hand gehen
müssen ja manchmal ist man im Alter
realitätsfern kritisierten Brüssel
wesentlich näher ampuls der Zeit als in
den Berliner Elfenbeintürmen außerdem
verändern die neuen modularen Reaktoren
die Realität in dieser Branche völlig
sie erfordern viel geringere
Investitionen und können viel schneller
gebaut werden und deswegen sind die
europäischen Länder bereits der
Atomenergie eine neue Chance zu geben
Sie Plan en neue Kraftwerke zu bauen und
das Wichtigste dass sie danach benötigen
ist kernstoff
[Musik]
ist der notwendig sein den Uranabbau in
den Minen zu erhöhen aber auch die
Raffineriekapazität um das Uran zu
verarbeiten und zu wandeln und
anzureichern und genau hier will
Frankreich eine führende Rolle spielen
in Paris arbeitet man bereits äußerst
entschlossen und tatkräftig daran wie
man an Schlagzeilen wie dieser erkennen
kann Frankreich er legt neue
Urananreicherungsanlage um die
Abhängigkeit des Westens von Russland zu
verringern nach Angaben eines Sprechers
von orano erblickt das französische
Staatsunternehmen zwei Optionen zum
einen den Bau einer
uranreicherungsanlage in den USA und zum
anderen eine Option die am schnellsten
und wahrscheinlichsten wäre nämlich die
Erweiterung der Kapazität seiner
modernen Anlage George Best 2 um 50%.
diese ist seit 2011 in Betrieb und
reichert Uran bereits mit der
zentrifugal Technik an die Menge bzw
Masse angereicherten Urans wird dabei in
Kilogramm und Theater gemessen OTA steht
für urantrennarbeit an dieser Größe kann
man die produktionskapaz von Uran
anreicherungsanlagen miteinander
vergleichen in der Anlage George Best 2
Reichert Frankreich 7,5 Millionen
Kilogramm OTA pro Jahr an eine
Steigerung und 50% würde die Kapazität
auf 11 Millionen Kilogramm OTA erhöhen
zum Vergleich alle sich momentan in
Betrieb befindlichen französischen
Atomkraftwerke benötigen etwa 6,5
Millionen Kilogramm das heißt 6500
Tonnen OTA das entspricht etwa 8000
Tonnen Natur orange Frankreich für seine
Atomkraftwerke importieren muss wenn es
also plan 11 Millionen Kilogramm OTA zu
produzieren muss es jedes Jahr mehr als
13.000 Tonnen Uran einführen und genau
hier bei könnte Niger ein Problem für
Frankreich darstellen
wie ich euch bereits gesagt habe kann
das Land auch fast 2000 Tonnen die es
jedes Jahr aus Niger importiert
verzichten was den Eigenbedarf angeht
dafür würde es ausreichend andere
Lieferanten finden die granation will
jedoch wie gesagt größere Ambitionen
erreichen und sie muss auch gegenüber
ihren Bündnispartnern eine höhere
Aufgabe erfüllen Frankreich braucht für
seine Strategie ein wichtiger Exporteur
von Kernbrennstoff und eine echte
Alternative zur russischen Vorherrschaft
zu werden mehr Organe viel mehr Uran und
es besteht kein Zweifel daran das macron
sein Land auf genau dieses Ziel zu
steuern Frankreich interessiert sich für
Uran aus der Mongolei Marcon und sein
Außenminister haben in den vergangenen
Monaten die Mongolei besucht dort haben
Sie Interesse an Investitionen in Höhe
von rund einer Milliarde Euro bekundet
um an das mongolische Uran und andere
Metalle wie zum Beispiel Lithium
heranzukommen natürlich hat man den Ulan
Bata die Gelegenheit beim Schopf gepackt
und macron mit offenen Armen empfangen
das geht sogar schon so weit dass dort
bereits davon die Rede ist Frankreich
sei der heute Nachbar der Mongolei einem
Land das wie ein Sandwich zwischen
Russland und China eingekeilt ist und in
diesem Sinne wird schon sehr bald ein
großes Abkommen erwartet okay das ändert
natürlich nichts an der Tatsache dass
nie gehört der Regierung in Paris im
Moment große Kopfschmerzen bereitet
vergesst nicht das Russland seine Macht
in der Sahelzone immer stärker ausweitet
und es könnte diese Macht dazu nutzen um
Uranlieferungen aus nieder zu seinen
eigenen aufarbeitungsanlagen umzuleiten
das würde zweifellos dazu beitragen die
Vormachtstellung des Kreml auf dem
kernbrennstoffmarkt weiter zu festigen
klar ist es handelt sich um eine
gewaltige strategische Herausforderung
Moskau denn es hat sehr viele Hirten vor
sich um diese zu bewältigen versuchte
Camel nun jede Strukturen zu übernehmen
und am Leben zu erhalten die der
gefallen
hinterlassen hat aber das ist schon
wieder ein Thema für ein eigenständiges
Video vergesst also bitte nicht das Abo
unbedingt mit Glöckchen falls ist durch
genauso interessiert wie uns und er es
nicht verpassen möchtet fakt ist nämlich
dass die bergbau-region im Norden ne
geht es um die es hier geht quasi
vollkommen autonom ist von der
Hauptstadt des Landes in der die
cremetreue Militär hinter das Sagen hat
der Grund dafür am Flughafen von Arlit
von dem aus Aldi begehrten Rohstoffe
exportiert werden unterhalten die
Gallier einen ständigen
Militärstützpunkt der mit Kampfjets
Reaper Drohnen und 1.500 Soldaten
ausgestattet ist und nicht nur das auch
Uncle Sam ist präsent am Flughafen
befindet sich nicht nur eine große
us-drohnenbasis nein insgesamt sind dort
mehr als 1000 G1 auf mehreren
Stützpunkten stationiert und zur
Sicherheit befindet sich vor Ort auch
noch eine geheime cia-basis aber der
springende Punkt ist dass dies wieder
Putsch in ihrem mal wieder gezeigt hat
wohl auch bitte nötig ist denn wenn die
ganze Welt wieder verstärkt auf Atome
Energie setzt darf der Westen dadurch
nicht seine Abhängigkeit von Russland
erhöhen es wird spannend bleiben in
Putin weiß das ganz genau und sie sieht
hier eine große Chance seine Macht
auszubauen deswegen dürfen wir uns nicht
wundern wenn wir sowohl in Afrika als
auch beim Thema cambrennstoff noch so
einige überraschende Schachzüge des
Kreml erleben werden aber keine Angst
wir werden euch wie immer auf dem
Laufenden halten damit ihr alle
wichtigen Zusammenhänge versteht und bis
dahin sind die Fragen erstmal an euch
gerichtet glaubt ihr das Frankreich mit
seiner Strategie erfolgreich sein wird
oder wird Russland im Spiel um die
uraneicherung den längeren Atem haben
und sollte eurer Meinung nach gerade in
diesen kritischen Bereich nicht ganz
Europa am gleichen Strang ziehen
schreibt uns eure Meinung gut
Einschätzung in den Kommentarbereich
unter diesem Video wie immer sind auf
eure Diskussion und Eure Anregungen zu
diesem Thema schon mächtig gespannt
außerdem hoffe ich dass euch dieses
Video gefallen hat und ihr vielleicht
etwas dabei gelernt habt falls ja geht
uns bitte ein Like heißt mit euren
Freunden und diskutiert ist auch mit
ihnen natürlich freuen wir uns auch
jederzeit über eine Spende von euch
dieses Projekt weiterzuführen den Link
dazu findet ihr in der Beschreibung
unter dem Video macht's gut und bis bald
[Musik]